when it comes to Comedy the only person
I care about is Norm McDonald I thought
it was a matter of record but apparently
there are other comedians in the world
and there's one guy who's completely
blowing up ticket sales and streaming so
I guess I got to check him out take it
away what's that know my mom your mom
plays professional basketball in the
WNBA yes no way so you definitely don't
come from
[Applause]
money that was a low blow I'm sorry but
was also such a layup you know was your
mom good yes would you say she was the D
Jordan of the
[Laughter]
D that is pretty cool though did you get
to go to a lot of games growing up yeah
I did you sat Courtside absolutely was
it
lonely some of that was funny the Dy
Jordan thing was very funny and he
obviously said it up perfectly it became
personal with me the only thing I don't
like is when comedians laugh at their
own jokes a little bit is okay but
otherwise I find it off-putting he was
really laughing at his own jokes but it
was pretty good he's obviously he's
talented Dy Jordan fun my roommate and I
we were walking to get lunch right in
North Hollywood like two blocks from my
house and as we were going into the
restaurant coming out of the restaurant
this beautiful girl right we both turn
we see her we recognize her it's um it's
Lisa Anne who ladies she's like like the
number one porn star in the world guys
you know who the I'm talking about
my roommate Caesar loses this sh he's
like dude D do you know who that is I
was like yeah I have a right arm I know
who that
is he's like totally fan girl and now
he's like will you take a picture for me
I was like come on don't be that dude he
like please please please fine whatever
hands me his phone runs over to her asks
her a picture she's very polite you know
yeah of course puts her on Mor's waist
they're posing I got the camera one 2 3
take the picture he's like you want one
he like of course go
over I go over my roommate has the
camera she puts her arm around my waist
we're POS him roommate has a camera he's
counting down one two three and on three
as he flashes the camera she leans in
and kisses me right on the cheek and my
roommate loses this it's like
oh the coolest ever but like I've seen
her
work so I'm
like what
that's pretty good what the Striking
thing here there are two striking things
about this one he appears to be wearing
overalls but down and then the other
thing also about his appearance is this
guy is very handsome I don't know that
I've ever
seen a handsome comedian this guy could
be like a male model that's really
weird CU I don't know I don't know
what's weirder that he is a very
good-look guy or that I've never seen a
really goodlook comedian man or woman
huh huh a funny setup though right now
go to jus.com
YT letter y letter T I have got a
Christmas gift idea that is sure to make
you the hero of the season and we all
know the holiday season can be a little
bit hectic the shopping the cooking the
long list of things to do if Fe not
because I've discovered a gift that is
both thoughtful and transformative the
gift of Janus cell skincare from now
until Christmas Jus cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at j.com letter y letter T
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin redness sagging Jael line
will disappear right before your eyes
with jus cell's most popular collection
Jus cell promises immediate effects you
will see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back their
products use the best stuff out there on
the market the prices are incredibly
competitive and in fact they will give
you special holiday discounts because
they know even if they look lose money
on this order they know that you are
going to keep coming back that is how
good it is go to Jus cell.com
nsyt get this incredible holiday
discount today every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping j.com
nsyt today what's your name bro Cory
Cory it's a very white name um it's
short for something it's it's short for
something What's it short for it's
Cornelius
cornelus do what bro you can't even say
the n-w if I'm being honest you can't
you don't get to say it
[Applause]
Cornelius ain't that the mother from
Rudolph The Rednosed Reindeer who's like
SE
there you
Cory my dude what do you do for work I
work for the Water Authority did you go
to college for that n you didn't go to
college there's the
black I did go to school for a little
bit to be a cop though you went to
school to be a cop back to
White interesting and why why' you bow
out politics and I was a better
Criminal Back to
Black who are you
Cornelius you're a mystery bro all the
lines are pretty good and he's fast and
he he's he's obviously got really good
comedic instincts and chops I just don't
love the delivery no matter what anybody
says you'll always be a prince to me
he's trying to seem just like a normal
guy but comedians are not just normal
guys I don't I wish he would lean more
into just being a fast funny comedian
than the you know the yucking it up with
everybody okay next one cannot make
jokes about trans people cuz what
they're going through is so incomparable
and you can't imagine how hard their
life is in the that they have to go
through therefore you cannot make jokes
about trans people and and I I I hear
you I hear you loud and
clear
but the point that you're trying to make
is you're saying I can't make jokes
about somebody because of how hard their
life is and you are making very valid
points and that I I don't know how hard
that life
is
but at the same time to retort that
argument you also don't
have the hardest life
you know who has life way harder than
trans people that we never talk
about people in
wheelchairs think about comparatively
people in wheelchairs have a much harder
life do they complain about it no we
gave them a couple of ramps and kept it
pushing let's let's say you took
somebody with with no
legs in a trans
person and you put them in the same room
the the same handicap accessible
room see who you think has the harder
life I just I feel like I'm trapped
inside of another person's
body so you have four
legs you're you're you're not listening
it's it's not about that it's a
sometimes my mental health will take
such a toll that I can just I could just
jump off of my
balcony
jump what's
that you're you're not hear people will
call me the wrong
pronouns someone called me Chariot
Tubman the other day you
think you think a pronal is the worst
thing you can be
called come
on what about a person in a
[Music]
wheelchair Oh you mean
Transportation so he's on the right
track he's and and some of that was was
really good and but he's like 12 years
old so he's I think he's just got a he's
got to fine-tune it like if he gave that
same set with more subtlety If instead
of you know if the pauses were cut down
by 30%
if the if the mugging to the camera were
cut down by if everything were just kind
of trimmed down by 30% I like it he just
needs to be like older and grizzled okay
next one baby
mama well that's
loyalty it sounds like if if he's
anybody should be the mother of his
child no am I crazy for this one it kind
of sounds like you breaking up a
[Applause]
family he's still in his house with his
wife and his
baby what's the
problem he doesn't with her no he said
he don't I think he ly yes he's
lying that's what we call a blatant
lie I mean maybe he should be he
shouldn't be dating you on the side if
he is actually interested in her I will
say that how long have you been seeing
him for four months four months so I my
best advice would be to either say break
up with them or also get
pregnant play this game okay yeah that
that bit was good he's right also like
his his reaction is Tethered to reality
and it was funny and it was unexpected
and obviously he really leans heavily on
the crowd work which can be very very
hard to do crowd work is not my favorite
kind of Comedy but it it can be
effective and he's he's promising young
man maybe someday when he's really old
and grizzled he'll be you know fine to
tuned ready for another episode of this
critical comedy review see you next time
what is that joke that you told recently
at the office everybody is just like
giggling about it all the time and I
haven't heard it yet oh gosh okay um all
right it goes like this so there's this
woman
and so you know that wasn't that wasn't
the punchline that wasn't the punchline
no the there's
more there's not
more